do you have any suggestions to help
writers brainstorm for ideas yes well
first of all let's just imagine that
we've got 10 tracks of our brain ok you
know that our brain can do 10 things at
one time one of those tracks if you're a
writer should be always sensitive to and
aware of ideas they're out there they're
out there all over the place they're in
newspaper articles they're in
conversations you hear with people at
the coffee shop they're on the radio
they're on click your click click thing
happens I know for example I know David
Rabinowitz and Charlie Wachtel who wrote
black Klansman and I interviewed them
and I said well how did you guys come up
with it in sure I think David said well
I was trying to avoid writing and so I
was just doing the click-click-click
thing and I stumbled on this Facebook
article about this guy Ron Stallworth it
was the first black policeman in
Colorado Springs who then did this thing
with the Ku Klux Klan so that's how they
discovered it so one thing is just be
conscious of it the other thing is be
intentional you know like everyday you
should be thinking about story ideas now
people are not going to necessarily you
know it's gonna vary from person to
person but there have been times in my
life where I literally said I'm going to
come up with an idea a day every day I'm
gonna come up and it's in and a third
point to that related his dr. Linus
Pauling who was the only person to win
two Nobel prizes and he has that saying
the best way to come up with a good idea
is to come up with a lot of ideas and so
that's a third point that you can do is
just generate a lot of ideas keep a file
like I've got a word file stretching
back 20-some odd years with literally
hundreds and hundreds of ideas most of
them awful but you keep working that
muscle and then eventually I think
chances are that you're going to surface
something now then you have to assess
the ideas and so there's certain
questions you can ask like well
is this big enough to be a movie you
know who's the audience for this what's
the hook you know that central conceit
like when I sold k9 you know I remember
going into an executives office and they
said come what you guys did was so
brilliant
you took the buddy action comedy formula
the police cop and you put in
rin-ten-ten who was like the biggest
star in Hollywood back in the late 20s
and 30s and I learned a very valuable
lesson there which is that you always
when somebody gives you a compliment
even if you didn't mean it you go yeah
that's exactly what I was thinking I
said yeah that's exactly what we're
thinking because I hadn't thought that
at all but you know you that idea I
could walk in at that point in time in
1987 I could have walked into any
producers office or any bar where people
were hanging out what are you working on
I said yeah I got this idea k9 loaner
cop new partner police dog they would
see that so the hook there is the police
dog nobody had done that you know so you
look for like inception the idea of
being able to go on side some of us
Groundhog Day we're living the same that
thing what's that thing that's gonna set
it off from you know something else so
those are some keys you know have one
part of your brain going be intentional
about it you know be generating a lot of
ideas and hoping that you'll come up
with you know some really good ones some
strong ones off that and then assess
them to make sure that you feel like
it's big enough and good enough to be a
movie
you